1 Joseph buck here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Joe I'm good I'm just
going over some of the different
character names on WKRP in Cincinnati
there was herb harlech there was Bailey
who was gorgeous back in the day Loni
Anderson I don't remember her name on
the show there was Venus flytrap there
was less Nessman one of the Blessed
Nessman the nerdy newsreader
mm-hmm of course you know dr. Johnny
favorite dr. Johnny fever was the guy
under Johnny fever and then you have got
in trouble and then trouble one episode
when he fell into the payola trap oh
that's right that was that was if I'm
not mistaken a very special WKRP that
night Joe we all learned something my
career where if I'm given like a free
pair of like a nice watch tonight yeah
they're on the air I can't I can't
accept it or if I do I can't talk about
it
mmm it's like some sort of free
promotion you raise the bar we already
know that Joe you raised the bar set
this can you set the stage for me
tonight what do you got for me
on tonight's yeah yeah you got your
typical AFC North battle here and here
in Cincinnati the Ravens and the Bengal
I think it'll be a good game actually
and you know our thing I think we're
very proud of our schedule on Thursday
nights but even the first two games that
are on the NFL Network I think there's
gonna be intrigue tonight I think there
will be next week with Sam darn 'old and
the Jets going to Cleveland to play the
Browns after hard knocks and people
fallen in love with the cast members
slash roster of the Cleveland Browns I
think the first two weeks then on end of
the Fox schedule be really good yeah you
got that and then Minnesota and the Rams
out here in Los Angeles for the first
one that's on on Fox for week four
I mean Indianapolis at New England week
five the Philly Giants game the first of
two meetings between them but tonight's
game I mean with the way that we saw the
tie between Cleveland and Pittsburgh
play out going up to and OH in division
is pretty huge
how much do you think of Lamar Jackson
we might see tonight do you think Jo
well I can only tell you that when we
talked to John Harbaugh he is a little
protective of that specific piece of
information and still considers him a
quarterback and a quarterback only
despite the fact that he lines up on the
outside process does all that stuff
right the quarterback who who lines up
on the outside I don't know I think
we'll see he was in essence in when the
game was still in the balance
against Buffalo five times early and and
maybe they might build on that I don't
think it's gonna be a lot more than that
I think they want to get Flacco going
you know he's coming off a couple of bad
years last year was down he had the bat
back he looked great in week one and and
so all that's well and good with Lamar
but I think you have to make sure that
that Flacco is on a roll or if he's not
on a roll can get on a roll that's your
best chance to win so they don't want to
be gimmicky they don't want to make it
kind of a sideshow so if that's the case
I don't think I think you know five six
times at the most and then for the
Cincinnati offense just in week one
seeing what they it looked like in
Indianapolis it looked to me more often
than not that the Dalton to green
connection that everybody thought is the
main engine of this offense it's now Joe
Mixon Joe what were you able to pick up
over the last 24 hours on that subject
yeah I thought it was interesting that
that a couple of guys not just AJ Green
his teammate but a guy that he'll be
facing and CJ Mosley kind of went to
Todd Gurley comparison route not saying
he is Todd Gurley but for a guy that had
basically 150 scrimmage yards against
the Colts you know he can run it he can
catch it he's he's fast he's not a
little guy he's six 1 to 20 the question
is going to be in this game
can this offensive line for Cincinnati
hold up against the pressure of speaking
of 80s and seventies sitcoms wink
Martindale 90 cents
you know there's they're gonna blitz
even more than they have in the past and
they prove that in the preseason they
proved that week one they had six sacks
and this offensive line on the right
side with regimen and Bobby Hart the
former giant they are going to have
their hands full and I would imagine the
tight end will be over there helping out
more times that's not trying to disclose
that pass rush
Joe Buck here on the Rich Eisen show
calling again tonight on the NFL Network
the first Thursday night game with the
Fox crew for the next six years right
here on the Rich Eisen show for the
moment you fresh off of that game in
Carolina and one thing that left off a
page at me what I read and I'm wondering
what your take is or if you I know you
don't speak for Troy but Stephen Jones
when presented with something that was
said in the broadcast in Carolina from
Troy saying that the offense wasn't a
very creative or he didn't see much
creativity out of the offense Stephen
Jones saying anybody can play armchair
quarterback what did you think about
that Joseph yeah well I first of all
they're very good friends and they've
talked since that came out and I think
that's kind of the blessing and the
curse of game troll totally makes a
statement like that everybody
straightens up in their chair on the
couch and goes oh whoa wow he just said
that the Dallas Cowboys are not creative
I I think it proves that he's willing to
be critical of the team that he took to
three Super Bowl wins which i think is
great for him and I think he's right I
mean I don't know anybody including dak
Prescott Jerry Jones other people
involved in that organization they can't
come out of that game against Carolina
happy with what they did offensively and
I think it starts with the offensive
line there too so when you don't have
Travis Frederick and you have a rookie
at left guard and you're taking on
Carolina I would imagine it does look
hard
it is hard to look creative or
imaginative if you can't block enough to
let something develop or to get it we
feel Elliott going there fine that that
whole Steven Jones Troy thing was
nothing but I don't know anybody who
would watch that game who would come
away impressed with the Dallas office
they're just gonna figure something out
and and see if their offensive line can
get better going into a big game against
the Giants
that is huge I mean it's just absolutely
huge certainly if the Giants with their
playmaker show up in the Jones Mahal and
shine out I mean putting extra pressure
on a team that might fall to Owen to
with the star on the side of the helmet
Joe I mean this is just this is is
something who do you think about Chris
Brockman here on the ridge Oh looking at
three quarterbacks from 2016 Gulf when
stack Prescott who do you think will end
up having the better career it's all
said and done well it's all said and
done I mean I think you have to take
into consideration the torn ACL for
Wentz I think when was the easy answer
and was in the MVP conversation when he
went down last year in December in LA
but I thought golf looked really good
against Oakland and I hadn't seen that
I'd seen him practice a couple years ago
and looked shaky and then when he got
the chance to really step in last year
with McVeigh they led the league in
offense and are in scoring and you know
if you're capable of doing that as the
quarterback something Goods going on
there and I thought he look even better
against Oakland on Monday night so I
think right now it's a toss-up between
went and Gotha and we'll just have to
see how whence comes back but I think
the easy answer is Wentz but I'm not
giving up on job yeah and so what let's
just get into the your schedule here so
when the World Series hit so you still
haven't due Thursday Night Football I
mean what does your schedule look like
Joe all that happens yeah I think so
will kind of put that together and I
think you know who knows he's going to
be in the World Series who's gonna be in
the LCS for that
that's exciting it just depends I'm kind
of where I am and if everything goes
well weather-wise and there no you know
push backs or postponements then I think
I would do all of them during it there's
only there's only two potential
conflicts one of the Game five of the
NLCS and the other is a travel day in
the World Series so I think I'll
probably stay in baseball during the
NLCS but I think all that's up at the
air till we figure out where and you
know when these games are it's exciting
Joe I mean the Red Sox won their 100th
last night the Yankees are only now one
game in front of the Athletics for the
home spot in that American League wild
card game the Rockies keep winning games
in the NL I mean do you have any sense
of who you think might you be calling in
the World Series when it's said and done
well we have we have the NL this year so
I mean that is totally wide I can't
remember a time where you go into the
postseason and you say I have no idea
not only who's gonna get in but but who
would make it through I mean the Cubs
lead is miniscule now as well and
they've got a hot Milwaukee team and a
resurgent Cardinal team right behind
them so it's it's throughout the
National League Boston is the best team
obviously their record tells you that
but there's no way they feel comfortable
with where they are with Chris Sale and
postseason history of David Price so if
that's the case then you know you look
at a Houston team that is good one
through five in their rotation yeah they
have holes in their bullpen but if you
have one through five in your rotation
that's really good one of those guys or
two of those guys could slide into your
pen and make that even better so I the
best teams are in the American League
and the National League is a complete
roll of the dice crafters all right and
so most importantly what are the reads
tonight during the game you can do NFL
gameday morning reads during the game
tonight you know okay
but he's our football life on Carson
Palmer okay there's that one any Fox
we're gonna
are we gonna get a you know a good I
guess lethal a Last Man Standing what do
we got you we got a nine on one I'm just
gonna go rogue and just keep saying
Bob's Burgers over that's look hey
that's that's what happens when you get
on when you get a long term contract
just at 14 don't forget to check out
Bob's burger hey did you see did you see
Mark Wahlberg's schedule I know if
you're on Instagram or anything like
that did you see what this is do you see
this yeah just tell me if this sounds
like yours okay because I know your your
your traveling man your your man who's
trying to stay healthy fit you got two
beautiful new babies you and Michele so
here here's what I I have a vested
interest as a 49 year old father of
Muhammad went to you know maybe take
bacon out of my diet exactly so here's
Mark Wahlberg Joe you tell me what you
think here starting at 2:30 in the
morning wake up how close is that to you
2:30 in the morning wake up normally
it's like 2:30 in the morning finally
getting to sleep okay all right 2:45
a.m. prayer time followed by a 3:15 a.m.
breakfast a 3:40 a.m. to 5:15 a.m.
workout okay hold on a second
post-workout meal then a shower golf at
7:30 before his 9:30 a.m. cryo chamber
recovery time so you don't so your
reaction is you don't cryo chamber
recover is that what you're saying I've
done that before and it it tests every
part of my manhood I've never done this
what do you get out of it it's you know
it's like doing that hot cold you know
getting a cold plunge it hot getting a
cold pot to get hot tub you eat it does
something for recovery yeah by freezing
your your blood and capillaries and
other parts of your body
yeah I mean that's by nine-thirty I
could go on and on his dick gets the
dinner he gets to bed by 7:30 and has
dinner at 5:30 like a lot of fun okay
well hey Joe could not be a nicer guy by
the way but I don't if that's everyday
no thanks I know that is awful that is
every day and then two hours for golf
that's very impressive that like in in
preparation for a role or is that just
life this said at the very top of his
Instagram story snapshot typical daily
schedule is how he put it
yeah I'm guy called BS on okay hard pass
that sounds like a new Fox series of
starting this fall hard pass I call a
hard pass or I call BS on that hosted by
Chris Byers
that's me here and you and the cryo
chamber there I call BS on call I call
the sounds good let's pitch it man that
sounds great
just do me a favor just really lay into
my name tonight when you give the read
for NFL gameday morning what are you
first of all you're not even here I know
yeah I'm nine that that came is
disappointment I found that out about an
hour to a slap should have warned you
should have warned you sorry to give me
the heads-up my apology but no yeah I'm
not there but just I'll still want a
shout-out just any shout-out just give
me a shout-out
okay yeah like a little tug on the ear
little Carol Burnett and we'll play it
tomorrow I have no idea what you do I'll
just leave it up to you I would never
tell you what to say at the end when I
sing at the end of our on-camera when I
sing I'm so glad we had this time
together and I just a sing a song I'll
tug on my ear and I'll give you a little
wink I can't wait
that'll be great Joe take care say hi to
Michelle
you take care that's Joe Buck everybody
yeah the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience
you